immune system of our body protects us
from harmful pathogens and that's why we
can compare our immune system with the
different system of a country which
protects us from all kind of enemies but
imagine our protectors which is to
protect us from all sort of harmful
effects turn their face against us and
instead of protecting our body they
start harming our own body and this kind
of situation happens during autoimmune
disorders but instead of protecting our
own immune cells like T cells B cells
and the plasma cells hit our own body
like remoted arthritis
well autoreactive T cells consider the
antigens of our body to be foreign and
they counter our own body and that's why
we get severe joint pins and distortion
of the finger joints same happens in
case of Hashimoto's thyroiditis where
autoreactive plasma cells produce
autoreactive antibodies against thyroid
gland and the thyroid gland gets
depleted and there is severe
inflammation of that tissue in my senior
gravis the situation is the same or too
reactive B cells produce antibody
against the postsynaptic receptor that
leads to abnormalities in the
neuromuscular Junction leading to severe
muscle pain and inflammation so all
these things tells us that when immune
system turned their face against us and
become rogue the situation could be
detrimental there should be some
safeguard mechanism which can protect
our body and ensures that our body is
protected from this kind of situation so
two questions are crucial to understand
first where does these autoreactive
immune cells come from and is there any
safeguard mechanism present in our body
which can prevent the production of
these autoreactive cells it turns out
there is a mechanism called immune
tolerance which works like a safeguard
mechanism
prevent the production of these
autoreactive cell that's protecting our
body from the harmful effect of these
autoreactive cells and in this video
we'll talk about the immune tolerance
immune tolerance could work in two
different levels like the central
tolerance and the peripheral tolerance
the mechanism is employed on T cell as
well as be said and we would learn about
both and at least have a bird's eye view
about that let's talk about the B cell
development first to understand the
tolerance mechanism during b cell
development lymphoid progenitor cell in
subsequent step give rise to immature
b-cell and in this immature b-cell you
have the b-cell receptor which can
recognize antigens but is that if they
recognize self antigens with very high
affinity or shows very strong BCR
signaling then body has to take a
preventive measure because there are
chances that this immature b-cells which
interact with very high affinity could
become rogue in future and they would
harm their own body so they could be
killed by apoptotic mechanism by a
programmed cell death or they could be
suppressed or they could go to a
hibernation by a mechanism known as
energy where b-cell receptors are down
regulated and there is a third way where
there is a the body gives chance to
these immature b-cell to re-edit
their PCRs such that they no longer show
high affinity to the self antigens and
all these mechanisms ensure that
autoreactive b-cell production is
prevented in the level of bone marrow
and this mechanism is known as central
tolerance mechanism just like we have
seen central tolerance mechanism there
is peripheral tolerance mechanism which
takes place in the lymph node which is a
peripheral limb for GaN in the
peripheral lymphoid organ generally the
immature b-cells populate there they
divide there
and undergoes clonal expansion they
undergo affinity maturation and class
switching ultimately they undergo
differentiation to produce plasma cells
but sometimes things can go wrong and
they create autoreactive plasma cells
which secretes autoreactive
antibodies against self antigens this
situation is detrimental and this
situation could lead to autoimmune
disease so what is peripheral tolerance
mechanism ensures that these
autoreactive b-cells on the plasma cells
would die by apoptosis and instead of
undergoing proliferation they undergo
clonal energy where baha'i burn it and
they don't react with other antigens so
these mechanism ensures that at
periphery tolerance is established this
leads to central and peripheral
tolerance of the b-cell in case of T
cell the situation is the same T cell
development is very stringent which
occurs in the thymus in the thymus when
the T cell enters five high endothelial
venule they reach the time'll sub
capsular region which is a peripheral
region of the thymus from there the
descent may increase in number by
rapidly dividing they descend down to
the cortex and they interact with primal
epithelial cell thymic epithelial cells
and that they learn many things from
them and they undergoes several
screening rounds they move to cortical
medullary junction where they encounter
again some other time epithelial cells
and eventually they move to medulla and
when their training is over they leave
the thymus but during this training
which is a long period which is almost
three-week they learn many things and
undergoes several rounds of screening
procedures and almost 90% of them don't
make it so first they have a double
negative stage when they don't have any
of the corset
they have only some aspect of the t-cell
receptor but no cd8 or cd4 receptor now
they transit to a double positive stage
where they have cd8 positive and cd4
co-receptor at the same time later on
this 80% of these cells would eventually
undergo a process of positive and
negative selection the positive
selection would ensure that it has to
recognize MHC s otherwise they would die
by neglect now if they cannot recognize
MHC MHC they're of no use so it's better
that they die but the cells which
recognize MHC VI plus 1 MHC or plus 2
MHC they survive and go to the next
screening process the next screening
process is called the negative selection
where the cells which interacts with the
MHC mountain a Samoan antigens with a
moderate affinity they go to the next
round moderate or low level of affinity
they go to the next round but if they
interact with the MHC bound peptide with
very high affinity then they're killed
by apoptotic mechanism or they undergoes
negative selection so I hope you enjoyed
this video
in this video I talked about how T cell
and B cell tolerance can save our body
from autoimmune disorders so if you
liked this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you